>> PRESIDENT TRUMP OFFICIALLY
KICKING OFF HIS 2020 REELECTION
CAMPAIGN LAST NIGHT IN FLORIDA
IGNITING THE CROWD WITH A WILD
75 MINUTE SPEECH.
HE DOUBLED DOWN ON CAMPAIGN
PROMISES AND TOOK AIM AT THE
DEMOCRATS AND CLAIMED TO BRING
AN EARTHQUAKE TO THE BALLOT BOX.
>> REMEMBER THE STATEMENT FROM
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION:
YOU WOULD NEED A MAGIC WAND TO
BRING BACK MANUFACTURING.
TELL SLEEPY JOE WE FOUND THE
MAGIC WAND.
WE ACCOMPLISHED MORE THAN ANY
OTHER PRESIDENT HAS IN THE FIRST
2.5 YEARS AND UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT A PRESIDENT
HAD TO DEAL WITH BEFORE.
IF I DELETED ONE EMAIL LIKE A
LOVE NOTE TO MELANIA, IT'S THE
ELECTRIC CHAIR FOR TRUMP.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BECOME
MORE UNHINGED THAN AT ANY POINT
IN THE MODERN HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY YOU AND OUR
COUNTRY AS WE KNOW IT.
A VOTE FOR A DEMOCRAT IN 2020 IS
THE VOTE FOR THE RISE OF RADICAL
SOCIALISM AND THE DESTRUCTION OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
AMERICA WILL NEVER BE A
SOCIALIST COUNTRY.
THE ONLY THING THESE CORRUPT
POLITICIANS WILL UNDERSTAND IS
AN EARTHQUAKE AT THE BALLOT BOX.
>> AND DEMOCRATIC CONTENDERS
WERE QUICK TO CRITICIZE THE
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH.
>> LISTENING TO TRUMP MADE ME
FEEL VERY MUCH THAT HE IS A MAN
LIVING IN A PARALLEL UNIVERSE.
A MAN WAY OUT OF TOUCH WITH THE
NEEDS OF ORDINARY PEOPLE, AND A
MAN WHO MUST BE DEFEATED.
>> THIS PRESIDENT WANTS US TO
KEEP LOOK IN THE REAR-VIEW
MIRROR INSTEAD OF THE FRONT
WINDSHIELD.
HE WANTS TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN INSTEAD OF MAKING AMERICA
GREAT TODAY.
WE NEED A LEADER OF OUR UNITED
STATES FOCUSSED ON THE
CHALLENGES OF THE 21st CENTURY.
>> JOE BIDEN ALSO GOING AFTER
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING THAT
TRUMP CONTINUES TO UNDERMINE OUR
STANDING IN THE WORLD AND OUR
CORE VALUES ARE UNDER ATTACK
HERE AT HOME AND ABROAD.
BIDEN TAKING CREDIT FOR TRUMP'S
BOOMING ECONOMY SAYING HE
INHERITED IT FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
DANA, BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT YOUR
REACTION, WE SHOULD NOTE THAT
THE PRESIDENT RAISED ALMOST $25
MILLION OVER A 24-HOUR PERIOD.
BIDEN THE DEMOCRAT RAISED THE
MOST WITH $6 MILLION.
>> I DON'T KNOW IN THAT'S A
GREAT COMPARISON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PULLING FROM
THE ENTIRE REPUBLICAN UNIVERSE
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE SPREAD
AROUND 25 PEOPLE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> $25 MILLION IN 1 DAY IS
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
NOT ONLY THAT, THEY ARE
COLLECTING MORE INFORMATION THAN
THEY EVER HAD BEFORE TO REACH
OUT TO THEM AGAIN.
WILL YOU WALK PRECINCTS AND SIGN
PEOPLE UP TO VOTE?
MAKE SURE YOUR NEIGHBOR GETS TO
THE POLLING BOOTH.
LAST NIGHT WAS INCREDIBLE.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WANT ME
TO TALK ABOUT.
MY OFFICIAL REACTION IS HE IN
GREAT POSITION AS MOST INCUMBENT
PRESIDENTS ARE.
HE IS PROBABLY IS IN EVEN BETTER
SHAPE THAN OBAMA WAS AND
CERTAINLY THAN PRESIDENT BUSH
BECAUSE OF THE WAR.
I THINK COMES DOWN TO 4 STATES.
THOSE 4 STATES, FLORIDA PROBABLY
THE MOST IMPORTANT, A REPUBLICAN
HAS TO WIN FLORIDA.
THAT'S WHY HE WAS THERE LAST
NIGHT.
THEY HAD A GOOD START.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT START.
GREG, ONE OF THE CENTRAL THEMES
OF LAST NIGHT WAS, IT WASN'T
ABOUT TRUMP.
IT WAS ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT PUT
HIM THERE.
HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR MOVEMENT
AND TAKING CARE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
LET'S REACT TO HOW HE POLLED HIS
OWN AUDIENCE TO SEE WHAT HIS
REELECTION SLOGAN SHOULD BE.
WATCH THIS.
>> I WILL ASK YOU TO VOTE ON IT.
I WILL MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN,
KEEP AMERICA GREAT.
LET ME HEAR BY YOUR CHEERS WHAT
YOU LIKE.
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> KEEP AMERICA GREAT!
>> WOW!
I AM SORRY, MAGA COUNTRY BUT
THAT WAS NOT CLOSE.
>> THAT WAS A GOOD MOMENT LAST
NIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A BIG
CHALLENGE HERE.
THERE ARE SO MANY OF THEM.
HE JUST MAKES THEM SEEM SO SMALL
BY HIS PERSONALITY.
IT'S POINTLESS FOR ME TO
CRITICIZE HIM.
I WAS WRONG ON THE INITIAL GO
AROUND.
I PICKED THE STRONG STOCK
BEFORE.
DON'T COME TO ME FOR INVESTMENT
ADVICE.
I WOULD HAVE LIKED MORE
UNSCRIPTED RIPPING.
THAT HELPS ME WITH MY SHOW.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> BUT THAT WILL COME.
I AM ARE INTERESTED IN THE MEDIA
RESPONSE.
ONCE CNN WAS CRITICIZED THEY
TURNED IT OFF.
YOU ARE A NEWS NETWORK.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO TURN IT
OFF.
WE CAN CHANGE THE CHANNEL, BUT
YOU ARE A CABLE NEWS NETWORK AND
YOU HAVE RESPONSES FROM MORNING
JOE AND CALLING HIM FAT ELVIS
AND THEY ARE TRYING TO READ
TRUMP'S MIND.
THEY REACT EMOTIONALLY TO THIS.
THE ECONOMY AND THE MILITARY AND
PRISON REFORM, ALL THAT IS LEFT
YOU CAN GO AFTER HIS PERSONALITY
AND MICRO-FLAWS IN TWEETS.
THE TRUTH I WISH THE MEDIA WOULD
UNDERSTAND IS THAT TRUMP IS A
CENTRIST.
I WENT THROUGH THE LIST.
STRONG MILITARY, PRISON REFORM.
CUT TAXES.
TRADE WARS.
REJECTION OF MILITARY ACTION.
LIBERTARIAN.
HE IS RIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO
HANDLE THAT.
HE IS WHAT AMERICA WANTS.
>> GREG BROUGHT UP THE MEDIA.
JUAN FOR AN INCUMBENT TO LAUNCH
HIS REELECTION CAMPAIGN IN FRONT
OF 20,000 PEOPLE IN PRIME-TIME,
THE MEDIA DID NOT TREAT IT THE
WAY IT WOULD TREAT A NORMAL
PRESIDENT IN THESE TIMES.
IT WAS OBVIOUSLY BLACKED OUT ON
CNN AFTER THE FIRST COUPLE OF
MINUTES AND MINCE MSNBC DID NOT
COVER IT SERIOUSLY.
THEY COVERED IT WITH SNARK.
THEY DON'T DISCUSS IT SERIOUSLY.
IT'S ALL SARCASTIC.
>> WE COULD USE A HYPE MAN.
YOU GOT A JOB OFFER HERE.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT MY
EXPERIENCE OF IT WAS SO
DISAPPOINTING.
IT WAS BORING.
I HEARD FROM ALL OF YOU THAT
TRUMP'S BIG ADVANTAGE IS HE IS
SUCH A GREAT ENTERTAINER AND SO
DIFFERENT.
YOU SAY THE MEDIA DIDN'T TREAT
HIM LIKE OTHER PRESIDENTIAL
INCUMBENTS, BUT HE IS DIFFERENT
THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
HE'S HAD 16 RALLIES OF KIND IN
2.5 YEARS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, HEY, THIS IS
LIKE A RETURN.
LIKE A SUMMER RERUN.
I HAVE SEEN THIS ACT BEFORE.
THERE WAS LITTLE NEW IN TERMS OF
AGENDA.
I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING NEW.
THE AUDIENCE IS SHOUTING LOCK
HER UP ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE WAS THE CANDIDATE IN 2016.
CNN SUCKS AND BUILD THE WALL.
I THINK HIS NUMBER 1 PROMISE IS
TO BUILD THE WALL.
NOW AGAIN BUILD THE WALL.
THERE IS NO AGENDA.
FAILURE TO DELIVER ON THE WALL
AND REPEAL AND REPLACE OBAMACARE
AND THE MIDDLE-CLASS TAX CUTS.
WE COULD ARGUE HOW MUCH THE
MIDDLE-CLASS BENEFITTED BUT THE
RICH BENEFITTED.
>> I CONSIDER MYSELF RICH AND I
GOT HIT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I PAID A LOT MORE.
>> YOU NEED TO GET RICHER.
IF YOU ARE WALL STREET, YOU
BENEFITTED.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT STUDENT DEBT
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INTERNATIONAL CHAOS IN IRAN AND
IRAQ AND CHINA, WHAT DID HE SAY
ABOUT THE NEWS?
>> WE COULD ARGUE ABOUT THE
AGENDA.
I THINK IT WAS BARACK OBAMA WHO
TALKED ABOUT GEORGE H.W. BUSH
FOR 8 YEARS.
>> NEVER ENDED.
>> NOW TRUMP HITS HILLARY
CLINTON A FEW TIMES.
>> GET A MOP.
>> TO CLEAN IT UP.
>> THERE IS A DIFFERENCE IN
PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT DID A
GREAT JOB OF HAVING THAT
CONTINUITY.
IN IS WHAT WE ACCOMPLISHED IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
HERE ARE THE CONTINUED THEMES I
AM WORKING IT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT HE SAID
BECAUSE IT WAS A SUCCESS FROM
THE GET GO.
PEOPLE LINED UP FOR 40 HOURS TO
GET INSIDE THAT ARENA.
THE TV CAMERAS SHOWED A PACKED
HOUSE.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT
WITH THE 2 NIGHTS OF DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATESES.
BERNIE SANDERS SAID IT WAS
NONSENSE.
TELL THAT TO THE PEOPLE WHO
STOOD IN LINE FOR 40 HOURS.
FUNERAL.
>> I THINK THE MONEY HE RAISED
WAS SOMETHING TO SEE.
I THINK THE INCUMBENT DEFINITELY
AS THE ADVANTAGE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IS TO
CELEBRATE.
IT LOOKED LIKE A REHASH.
>> WELL, HE'S HAD SUCCESS.
REPLAY IT.